[Music]
[Laughter]
the queue you are eh Salvo full
because I'm dead I'm going to weigh myself on August 27th
help me
[Music]
little little hot a Sony o dos
emplati modification
[Applause]
[Music]
I remember the
mutual statue on bridge
[Music]
of sciences
I feel
male I want I think it's
I feel perfectly fine
that we change sex that we change
the that assists a body
of the body I don't study it is
I know why If we change that or to the
cow that yes  changing shadows Why
Why don't you feel
physically
mysterious
because
first and I get on or
and the only moment it goes up not put
it's on the truck I have a
professional friend of the change I'm
incorporating
the same directly
[Music]
any restaurant
as a price list then after
[Music
] humanity
] take away
[Music]